ça veut dire non seulement vous mangez
et vous mangez bien fort c'est une
tuerie ouais c'est top euh jeis
remercier nos amis qui font de la tech
et du
wood ah oui ça tu cool c'est pour Noël
il nous l'ont offert alors les chéris il
y a je vous le dis c'est très simple il
y
a un robot à faire gagner pour une
personne du public ah génial génial
super pour cela c'est très
simple je vous ai dit que quelque chose
tout à l'heure on va revenir sur les 10
cadeaux top 10 des cadeaux préférés des
Français j'en ai donné quelquesuns ouais
vous allez devoir me donner les 10 VO
qu'est-ce qu'il y a alors vous prenez
l'argent tu vas sortir comme
Jean-Michel public ils vont sortir les
mec rien à même dans le public je
vais les sortir j' rien à c'est
très simple
lesen vous allez devoir me dire à chaque
fois le top 10 des cadeaux préféré des
Français pour Noël qui se
rappelle celui qui aura donné le plus de
bonnes réponses parmi les chroniqueurs
pourra choisir une personne du public
qui gagnera le robot oh là là incroyable
[Applaudissements]
ok qu en train de tricher non non mais
toi déjà alors toi déjà ah ouais lu il a
triché il a déjà regardé sur T tu es
éliminé tu es
éliminé tu es éliminé tu es éliminé et
je vous le dis j'en donnerai un au
chroniqueur en plus qui gagne
jàlimé déjà éliminé toi tu es éliminé
allez c'est parti on y va il y a bonne
réponse manzvous le cul oui parfum non
non non donne une fois parfum parfum
parfum oui c'est bon c'est en trè
position je l'avais dit tout à l'heure
livre livre livre je vais prendre un
produit culturel ça peut être un livre
je le prends bonne réponse de
Valérie un voyage un voyage il par fait
pareil
un bisou bisou bisou un voyage c'est bon
bon un bon achat un bon aachat tu tu tu
tu comprends un peu les
règles un bon d'achat c'est pas mal une
carte cadeau c'est bon je prends bonne
réponse bravo bonne
réponse de l'argent oui mais c'est trop
facile de l'argent l'argent ah dans le
nez bam j'ai envie de prendre ton nez
pour une trousse allez c'est
parti oui bonne réponse c'est le premier
oui mais c'est
facile elle a rien compris non mais elle
elle a rien compris maintenant il y a
tout le reste je l'ai pas dit plus tu
galoches plus tu es con alors moi
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux bah non je
pensais à un bijou bijou un bijou un
bijou un bijou de famille un un bijou
mais pour moi un bijou de famille j'en
ai marre moi oui bonne
réponse pour l'stant un point un point
un point un point un point des vêtements
des vêtements oui un vêtement pour
[Applaudissements]
16%
si je puis me permettre c'est beaucoup
plus difficile de de parler en dernier
oui mais c'est comme ça alors la
technologie technologie je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure bonne réponse exactement
[Applaudissements]
produit normalement c'est là que ça va
jouer Chud voilà c'est là que ça va
chouer on a fait on a fait article de
sport non non c'est des
vêtements une trottinette électrique non
produit produit électroménager ouais non
non il a triché il pas dit j'en ai rien
à tu es éliminé si je Tai vu il
est très lourd les deux les deux vous
êtes éliminés supporte pas la
trich atts regarde la BAR je lu pas par
je
triché triché il a triché regarde j'ai
pas triché j'ai déjà fait gagner un
cadeau à cette j'adore qui est venu avec
son mari est-ce que tu l' vu
tricher voilà éliminé c'est une cabale
éliminé oui de l'électroménager mais non
c'est itex pareil j'aime pas ta
gueuleex pareil de l'électroménager très
bonne réponse
VO
rien un animal de compagnie mais non
chien ça peut SFF un bouquet de fleurs
un bouquet de fleurs non euh vin
spiritueux champagne non ah cétait pas c
bien vu un air Fryer mais non il est là
non c'est l'électroménagerce qu'il est
électroménager jou attention je vais
vous dire maintenant ou je remets tous
les compteurs à zéro celui qui trouve
part avec le robot et choisira une
personne du public pour lui faire gagner
le robot d'accord attention c'est parti
vous pouvez proposer des jouets des
jouets non des jouet non la lingerie
non allez du chocolat non ah ouais un
cadeau je l'ai dit tout à l'heure ah bon
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure oui je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure allez un resto non
des produits de beauté qu'est-ce que
vous avez dit produit de beauté des
crèmes qu'est-ce que vous avez dit des
produits vous avez dit quoi bï produit
de beauté vous avez dit quoi benï prod
bï qu'est-ce que vous venez de dire des
crèmes des produit de beauté
benï des produits de beauté des produits
de beauté ouais avec ou hors parfum hors
parfum parce qu'on a déj parfum parfum
hor parfum c'est une bonne
[Applaudissements]
réponse
je la personne que choisira benim
repartira directement avec son robot ça
veut dire voilà elle part direct
avec toi aussi tu pars avec tout de
suite he bien sûr par avec tout de suite
donc vas-y tu vas le donner à quelqu'un
tout suite vas-y tu donnes à quelqu'un
de ton
choix je pas prends qui tu
veelqu tu veuxelqu'un qui vient tu
veux tout le monde tu
veuxz quelqu'un qui vient non mais la
dame là voilà dame là voilà merci avec
[Applaudissements]
plaisir je suis très heureux d'avoir
fait gagner la sœur de ma
lesg M6 merci bonsoir comment vous vous
appelez Françoise salut Françoise merci
d'être là ma m oui je suis je
suis je suis timide un grande timide
vous fa quoi dans la vie rien
à la retraite
oui elle elle a un
mec il est en
plus mais nonç ch
c'estoun Françoise j'ai une question à
vous
poseroir une idée
double fait je te dis la
vérité il y a C robots qui se sont
libérés mais c'est toi qui va choisir ou
bien tu fais choisir cinq robots à ces
cinq personnes que tu ne connais pas
derrière toi ou bien tu gardes le tien
mais je garde le
mien c'est quoi ce jeu oui je vais te
dire un autre truc Françoise il y a 10
robonss qui se sont libérés o tu fais
gagner ces 10 personnes que tu ne
connais pas ou bien tu gardes le tien je
garde le M je garde
le SAL les Chéries je vais poser une
ultime question à tout le public
Françoise oou tout le
[Applaudissements]
public je vous le dis où tout le public
repart ce soir même avec le robot parce
qu'il repart ce soir même avec le robot
grâce à nos partenaires Wood et tech OK
ou bien Françoise garde le sien par
contre les autres n'en ont pas c'est ou
Françoise ou tout public Françoise tu
peux dire franoise je le garde tu
[Applaudissements]
Gard pour onou tout de
suite